hey there guys so we watch a trailer
today Man of Steel trailer number two it
looks amazing I'm very pumped for it
now let me explain something I saw the
first Man of Steel trailer and I was
like you know okay well let's see what
happens it's a teaser you know it's a
teaser I liked the fact that they were
going in a more serious direction even
though it seems like all the superhero
movies nowadays it's like okay well the
Dark Knight was amazing dark gritty so
let's make it dark religion and you know
for some things that would work I'm glad
the Avengers wasn't like that because
that needed to be more can't be all the
cheesy yeah but for this Christopher
Nolan's producing it Zack Snyder looks
like he's rating himself in a little bit
not he found himself I think it was home
so I really hope this trailers true to
the tone of the film and that they're
not just showing the best shots because
it looks like he's not going all like
let's make everything all Sumi in
slow-mo and everything it looks actually
pretty good yes Snyder he's always been
a good visual director he just needs
someone to kind of hold on to his
coattails and pull him back a little bit
and if he's not writing the script it's
probably gonna be a good movie some of
the things I like about this trailer is
first of all this is a trailer that has
really a really nice song in it you
can't really say that about the movie
cuz I'd probably be in there but the
song is pretty cool epic depth to it
it's kind of not over-the-top action
Michael Bay it's kind of like brings you
back home and makes you feel a little
bit more personable towards the Superman
as a person less like he's like this God
you know that you don't understand I'm a
fan of the original film with
Christopher Reeve the first Superman
movie that's a good movie in that movie
though like his father was really
exceptive of Superman like show your
powers one day and everyone will love
you and blah blah blah and this one
Kevin Costner was like maybe you
shouldn't have saved those kids on the
bus don't share that Clark the
military's gonna put you in a cage the
rest your life but I like the fact that
Kevin Costner had that attitude and it's
more realistic than because but it's
more real-world that a father would be
like concern about how people are gonna
treat his son or his adoptive son you
know and not just like oh just go do
whatever son go stop the trains and
we'll go get shot with bullets and not
die as he vel'koz me yes
yeah by the way Kevin Costner I really
always liked him as an actor always like
you might need to only somebody he could
be like my uncle in real life like I'm
Ohio I don't advise me like candy bars
and I don't know go over to Kevin
Costner's house and play baseball
she's like a father figure yeah then
ghosts come out of the cornfields and I
liked a real father
Maximus Marius Decimus Russell Crowe
badass man I hope that that's good I
like him a lot as an actor I've never
seen him giving a bad perform another
another thing you get the trailers we
actually get some shots on the Krypton I
think I like about this trailer is that
it shows Superman a little bit as a kid
you you know the original film did that
but it just looks a little bit more
personal in the sense that it looks more
relatable but also the shots of him as
Superman looked pretty awesome like now
Henry Cavill got pretty damn ripped yeah
and I hope he's good because honestly I
haven't seen one performance from him
that has made me terribly excited about
the fact that he's Superman it's a good
thing though Superman and Clark Kent are
kind of both bland people if you can
give a little bit of motion and come off
as a badass that's all I'm looking for I
hope so I just want to see Superman
actually use his powers in a way other
than saving people who are falling off
buildings or welding some bars together
give him a guy to fight give him a guy
to showdown again so that's why you got
General Zod played by Michael Shannon in
this movie Superman - oh if you saw sir
I did yes he's basically you know he's
General Zod you kneel before Zod that's
what you do and I really hope that he's
awesome in this movie that he's like a
legitimate opponent I just really I
think he's gonna really push him to his
limits um another celexa Luthor you know
yeah I have a real estate scheme I'm
gonna stop the Man of Steel somehow
exactly
Oh darted I went to prison in the end